خمس سنوات استغرقها التحقيق الذي انتهى
الى توجيه الاتهام الى الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب واستدعائه للمحكمه
ففي عام 2018 اقر محامي ترامب مايكل
ديكوهن بارتكاب جرائم فيدراليه من خلال
دفع اموال لامراتين عام 2016 مقابل صمتهما
عن تجاوزات اخلاقيه ارتكبها معهما فتح
المدعي العام في منهات تحقيقا في الموضوع
لكن سرعان ما اغلقه بطلب من مدعين
فيدراليين كانوا يحققون في القضيه نفسها
بعد عام من ذلك اصدر المدعون الفيدراليون
مذكره استدعاء لمنظمه ترامب واخرى لمحاسبه
وطالبوا بالاقرارات الضريبيه الشخصيه
لترامب وشركاته لمده ثمانيه اعوام جادل
محامو ترامب بانه لا يمكن ان يخضع الرئيس
الح بتحقيق جنائي ودعوا لحمايه اقراراته
الضريبيه وهو ما جعل القضيه تستغرق وقتا
اطول في عام 2020 حكمت المحكمه العليا بان
ترامب ليس له الحق في منع الوصول الى
اقراراته الضريبيه وان الرئاسه لا تحميه
من التحقيقات الجنائيه وفي عام 2021 تسلم
المحقق الفيدرالي سجلات ترامب الماليه بعد
ان رفضت المحكمه العليا استئنافه لمنع
الافراج عنها بعد عام استقل اثنان من
المدعين بسبب تحفظات المدعي العام الجديد
لمنهاات بشان القضيه وقال احدهم في خطاب
استقالته ان ترامب مذنب بارتكاب العديد من
الجنايات في ديسمبر حقق المدعي العام نصرا
كبيرا بعد ادانه شركه ترامب بالاحتيال
الضريبي وجرائم اخرى
في مارس الماضي نشرت ترامب على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
اخبارا عن احتمال اعتقاله خلال ايام ودع
مؤيديه الى التظاهر دعم الله